[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
my name is Freddy gray I'm the deputy
editor of The Spectator and I will be
your host for this week's show it's been
quite a week in politics uh the week
began with soel bravman being sacked and
then the Lazarus likee uh reappearance
of David Cameron amid other bits of
reshuffling from Run's government uh I
will be talking uh about that first of
all with Kate fall baroness fall who was
David Cameron's right-hand woman when he
was prime
minister and John Redwood
MP next we'll look at the labor party
which is also having difficulties this
week um over a rebellion against kir
starma to do with the conflict in Gaza
uh and a parliamentary vote on a
ceasefire that was defeated I'll be
joined by James heel and Carl schin who
used to advise Jeremy Corbin and is now
a political communication
strategist amid all the political
turmoil there has been a little bit of
good news um for the government and for
Britain more generally in that inflation
is at last coming down or so it seems uh
based on October's figures I will be
joined by none other than Kate Andrews
our economics Editor to discuss what
that means and finally we will talk
about the rise in loneliness and single
people and the connection that might
have uh with social media and
smartphones I'll be joined by Dr Jean
uh one of the world's leading experts on
this subject and the ever brilliant
Louise
Perry before we get going I should say
that you should subscribe to this
channel if you don't do it already
there's already
325,000 people who have made the very
wise decision of clicking that subscribe
button which you'll find at the bottom
of your screen uh I urge you to do that
and make sure that you never ever miss
an episode by clicking the Bell icon as
well
well and of course we should thank our
brilliant sponsors canac cord genuity
wealth management canac cord our
experienc wealth planners and investment
managers who offer unwavering support in
these challenging times to find out more
information about them visit Cano
wealth.com
I was the future once said David Cameron
in his last day in office as prime
minister well um as The Spectators cover
piece by Katy bull says this week uh he
is the future once again after rishy
sunak on Monday surprised Everyone by
bringing back David Cameron as his new
foreign secretary uh amid a reshuffle a
bigger reshuffle um I'm joined to
discuss this very surprising development
with uh Kate fall baroness Kate fall who
was uh David Cameron's uh adviser uh for
a long period of time and uh John
Redwood MP I can't think of two better
people to talk about this subject with
um Kate I will start with you uh
everyone was surprised may I ask if you
were surprised did you have an inkling
this was your
thing I had an inkling but only just
before uh that um that um it was
happening and I think yeah I think it
was a very commendable um of rishy to
reach out to to um a tall poppy in his
put a tall Poppy in his cabinet um I
think David Cameron has the experience
and status to be a really great foreign
secretary at a time when you know that
the world is um really in a very
difficult place with Middle East and
Ukraine Rising tensions with China so um
yeah I thought it was a very interesting
and good appointment uh there's been a
lot of talk this week about you know the
fact that he's a serious politician that
he brings skills and experience and so
on uh I suppose the fact that the story
didn't leak might help uh add for the
fact that uh that he is a is a proper
politician because um generally when in
the Tory party in the last few years
we're not used to um than being able to
keep surprises is would you describe him
as a consument
professional no he he absolutely is a
consent professional um he he was very
very um good and very focused on that
wider National Security role at his time
in number 10 people often don't realize
that almost 50% of the prime minister's
time is spent on that sort of work beef
if you include you know home office
Affairs as well and he's he is
passionate about it it was sort of great
and reassuring to see him today I
thought with zilinski I'm sure he'll be
turning his attention also to the Middle
East and I think when we look to next
year when you've got all these big
elections coming not least with the USA
a sense of um will there be a vacuum in
in in sort of Global Leadership the fact
that you have David Cameron there on the
world stage when Wishy obviously prime
minister does some of that but you'll be
spending quite a lot of time thinking
about the general election so good
reassuring I thought well you say that
Kate but there are uh quite a lot of
criticisms of David Cameron's foreign
policy as prime minister and perhaps
quite a few very valid criticisms I mean
let's start with uh brexit which
obviously went wrong for him in a big
way uh you could also Point towards
Libya um where he was very much behind
the intervention uh that ended up being
a disaster for the region possibly
creating Isis or certainly bolstering
Isis uh and then lastly of course there
is this issue of China um where he was
very much behind the Golden Age um and
Rashid Sak's Administration appears or
appeared to be uh very different on its
position with China and there are some
lots of questions about the amount of
money that he has taken um possibly to
shill for China in the last few years I
mean that's quite uh that's three rather
big things that um he can be criticized
on foreign
policy so just dealing with that I mean
starting with brexit look David Cameron
put the question of our membership of
the European Union at a point when
people were feeling worried about where
that was going to the British people he
argued for us to stay he lost that
argument and resigned so I I don't think
that is um a failure I think it's it
would have been failure if he hadn't put
it to the British people um Libya look
one of the most difficult jobs as a
prime minister is that question on your
watch what do you do to save lives often
there's no perfect solution there's a
cost to either thing so that with liby
he went in he was passion trying to stop
a terrible situation with China I think
that is you know a very interesting live
issue I'm sure John Redwood will have a
view on this look at the time when David
um cam was prime minister he put forward
a a strong
Prosperity um sort of narrative with
China but there was always the National
Security the human rights angle you know
the sovereignty issue but also China has
changed and she was only just in place
during that time and look he's moved
towards a much more
authoritarian um um way of running China
we have terrible things happening in
Shing Jang we have what's going on on
Hong Kong and I think you know David
camon will react to China of now not to
uh where it was all those years ago so
that would be my my answer on the
foreign policy
piece John I'll bring you in uh you've
seen a lot of reshuffles in your time
what was your reaction to What happened
on
Monday I think it was a great pity um my
advice to Prime Ministers which they've
always ignored is not to have General
reshuffles they they are usually bad
news and I've never known one that
suddenly changes fortunes of the
government favorably I think we need
much more professional management of
ministerial talent and MP Talent there
needs to be proper Talent mapping there
needs to be mentoring and encouraging um
ministers need be given a defined task
and it needs to be reviewed on a regular
basis by the uh immediate Superior uh so
that you don't get to a point one or two
years in where you're standing by your
phone not knowing whether you're good
bad or indifferent whether you're going
to be promoted or sacked it's totally
unacceptable and you create too many
people who don't like you as prime
minister it's quite a few of the people
who sacked didn't particularly deserve
to be sacked it's just some argument
about oh we need to open it up to
different types of people or something I
think David Cameron was more skeptical
than most about reshuffles sort of got
talked into them uh but this one I think
um did backfire badly as we've seen and
we now have to get behind the new team
to try and get the show back on the road
get people talking about what really
matters which is what work are we doing
for the country how are people's lives
going to be better how are the
conservatives going to stop the small
boats get the economy growing and get
inflation down
as quickly as possible because those are
good
aims but they were knocked a bit by the
events of the last few days there is a
among uh people in sw1 or Tories in sw1
you do pick up a certain Nostalgia for
the Cameron years because they came
before brexit and the chaos of brexit
and they came before the pandemic and
the disaster of the pandemic and you do
pick up this sense that in the Cameron
years uh possibly because they're in
coalition uh the Tory party had uh more
drive more sense of purpose more
competence do you agree with
that no I don't agree with that
formulation I think David's great
achievement was to give us the
referendum I agree with Kate on that was
one of those who wanted a referendum I
was delighted when he saw the wisdom of
doing it I was sad that he backed so
strongly the side that I always thought
was bound to lose Associated himself
with a set of totally bogus some wildly
wrong economic
forecasts in an effort to say that
Britain as an independent country
couldn't do well I thought that's very
disappointing and I understand why he
resigned I think now he is our foreign
secretary and I've always found him
friendly and easy to get on with he's a
great communicator he's very able I
think those are all great things in the
minister so I wish him every success now
he is our foreign secretary but I think
he does need to
reassure uh the half of of the country
that desperately wanted to leave the EU
and wants the government that strongly
believes in brexit and starts using
freedoms it's given us because we not
using many of the freedoms we've gained
we need
reassurance from our foreign secretary
that his thinking has moved on that he
knows he's part of a brexit government
which was elected on that single pledge
really to get brexit done and would he
help us get it done properly because
we're still too tied to some of the EU
laws and problems and there are huge
opportunities and he should above all
tell people as I do uh that our big win
already is that the EU is spending and
borrowing on a colossal scale than the
UK would have had um much bigger demands
on on our money for EU purposes and we'
have had to guarantee the debts of
others through the EU borrowings and
isn't it great that we don't have that
added
complication in a difficult economic
situation Kate there's a lot of talk
about rishy trying to bring the tor
party back to the center ground with by
bringing Cameron back uh and possibly
sort of pushing himself away from the
Tory right uh do you buy that or do you
think it's media piffle I think bringing
David ceron back was really about
putting someone really serious in that
very important post at this time I also
think there was an element of sort of
trusted advisor I mean there is no doubt
that as a leader of a party especially a
prime minister when you come into an
election there is a bit of sort of
loneliness power you know the weight of
that falls on your shoulders you you're
putting yourself up for election on
behalf of your party I think having
someone um with you there who
understands that feeling will be you
know really really helpful to Rishi in
terms of the sort of center right I mean
it does look I think people think that
because sella bra and left as David CA
came in so they see those two together
um but overall I think that the
reshuffle seemed to me to be quite
balanced he brought in Esther MC
he's put in people that he likes and
respects this was his first time it was
much more his cabinet his government he
inherited really um from Liz and didn't
want to fire a whole bunch of people
when he came in so I just think it's a
very personal set of appointments John
what what do you think about all the
talk of sunak effectively giving up on
the red wall uh trying to shore up the
blue wall with this
reshuffle well I don't think that's the
right interpretation and it would be a
crazy policy because you've got to
address both audiences and on some
issues the two audiences are actually
United they' both like some tax cuts and
some growth so that the kind of things I
recommend are designed to bring the
party together around good conservative
policies that would improve the economy
improve the lot of British people and
would actually be good news in in both
parts but I I don't think he's Cut Loose
from the red wall because he's number
one aim he keeps on telling us is to
stop the small boats and that's much
more popular in the red wall than it is
in the so-called blue wall seats where
more people more relaxed about numbers
of people coming into the country uh so
no I don't think he's given up on on
that at all I think what he's got to do
though um is to cut loops from some of
the extremely bad official advice he's
been getting on on everything from
migration to the economy and inflation
because the the official advice has been
followed too slavishly and we've ended
up with borders are not under control
We've Ended up with an inflation rate
that was more than five times the bank
of England's Target and more than five
times the bank of England's
forecast and we've ended up with no
growth at a time when uh you can get the
economy growing as we see over the
Atlantic with the United States of
America recording 4.9% growth in its
most recent figures despite itself
having a bit of a monetary problem and
crunch as well Kate you mentioned Zing
ping earlier
uh and his authoritarian turn uh he had
a meeting with Joe Biden yesterday uh
which seems to have gone fairly smoothly
obviously differences of opinion on lots
of things and Joe Biden at the end uh
called j jingping a dictator again uh
I'd like to ask you do you think David
Cameron thinks that Zing ping is a
dictator and how do you you said earlier
that he he's because China has changed
David Cameron's position may have
changed a little bit but he hasn't
changed Cameron hasn't changed much on
China it seems to me up until very
recently I mean only three weeks ago he
was in Sri Lanka uh speaking in support
of the Columbo Port project which is a
big China funded project uh and I I
accept that he wasn't being paid
directly by China or anything but for
that but yet it is clearly supporting uh
Chinese expansionism which concerns a
lot of people um how's he going to
handle
China so I mean obviously you you'll
have to ask him um that I mean look it
was interesting to see um Biden and she
meeting yesterday there is a sense that
um everyone in in the west has become
much more uh scrutinizing of China
especially on the economic front so
calling out um concerns that they have
over human rights National Security and
sovereignty for us in Britain obviously
Hong Kong is top of that agenda um but
the Americans more focused on Taiwan and
and that's a focus for us too but there
is also the sort of economic Prosperity
angle to this and I'm talking about
British prosperity and I think you know
we want to try and find a balance don't
we to make sure that we we scrutinize
but we also make sure that we you know
do trade with one of the the biggest
economies in the world and it's a m it's
about finding a balance and being you
know really careful about it um I also
got the impression looking at that
meeting that you know the Americans are
trying you know to create some sort of
they don't want it to get out of hand
when the the Chinese balloon went up the
other day there was a concern that no
one knew who to phone it wasn't like the
old days with the Soviet Union where
they had the sort of red phone so I mean
there it's the most important
relationship and I really hope we get
that right and I think we need to be
careful but we need to be addressing
British interests at all the time and
working with our allies especially in
the G7 which has become a really
functional unit um in terms of trying to
get this one right John what you think
about that do you think uh the last few
years have shown that uh for the global
economy to function for the West for
America for
Britain uh China is just uh something
we're going to have to deal with we're
going to have to work with um and that
people like David Cameron and perhaps to
a certain extent Joe Biden uh have the
right approach in being accommodating uh
where they
can well I don't think there's any point
in in making an enemy unnecessarily but
you've got to be real real istic about
China and I think um the West has been
very unrealistic about China I think
they haven't understood uh just what a
brilliant strategy for China she has
developed in order to dominate markets
where we no longer have a strong
presence I mean for example it is the
West that is uh taking their respective
economies on on the road to Net Zero
China isn't China is still expanding her
CO2 output to the World on quite a big
scale produces 30 times as much as the
UK and yet it is China that has bought
up all the reserves and Technologies and
put in the production capacity to make
the batteries and the electric cars and
the solar panels and the wind turbines
that we we may now have to buy as
imports from them and I think this this
shows that the West Was negligent in the
way it responded to the the commercial
challenge of China um Kate says we need
to protect the trade we there any
problem about protecting the trade
because it's more important than export
and China at the moment still wants the
the revenues from selling us things um
the issue which UK has got to Define for
itself as America is increasingly doing
so for herself is on what terms do you
allow Chinese trade and we are
getting rightly I think much more
nervous about things that entail
technology sharing or gifting or sending
technology to the Chinese
uh given how good they are at exploiting
it and how we need basic capabilities
and basic producting productive
capacities at home uh for a whole
variety of self-sufficiency and defense
reasons Jord and Kate I think we'll end
it there but thank you both very much
for joining spectator
TV now rishy sunak has been having a
very difficult week but it's not exactly
an easy week for Kia starma um last
night in the common 56 labor MPS voted
against him after a three line whip
after a labor three line whip on the
issue of Gaza and the
ceasefire um I'm joined Now by James
heel our political correspondent and
Carl schin who was formerly director of
strategy for Jeremy Corbin and now works
for
survation uh James I'll start with you
um richy T had the Rwanda deal smash
into a legal wall pretty bad week for
him overall I think we can say uh people
a bit Bamboozled by Cameron uh and the
Tory right rebelling a little bit
against him um do you think K starma
arguably is having a worse week I would
say probably not uh just as a sort of py
summary but um as a longer form of that
let me say that I think that you know R
obviously on the Wednesday had the good
economic news which was welcome about
harving inflation but that's been
completely kind of sidetracked by what's
been happening on this Rwanda deal and I
think that there was a press conference
there after yesterday afternoon in which
it left us with more questions and
answers whereby we're expecting to see
some legislation brought forward under
which we're going to have a treaty with
Rwanda whereby um it's going to try and
address the Supreme Court's concerns
about um people who are you know being
deported back to their home country from
Rwanda but I think there's a lot of MP
sort of scratching the heads going
around not sure yet what's going to
happen so we're waiting to see in the
kind of days and weeks ahead what's
going on um then of course K dama a few
hours later after that had this vote in
the house of Comm
lost 10 front benches either from
resignation or um because they were
sacked including two bps's um but I
would say that looking at the polls the
polls of anything are going even worse
the conservatives so although this issue
of the splits over Gaza is going to be a
very real one and I think it's going to
persist as long as there's s of the
ongoing conflict in the Middle East um I
think that much more electorally
significant are the Wes facing Richi
sunak and the inability of the
conservatives either to find a sort of
moment which is going to shift the dial
and all this or second all get any
political credit for some of the the
smaller achievements that they've tried
to do so I think for those reasons it's
been a worse week fora than it has yeah
it was quite a desperate question for me
at mly to try and suggest that that Kor
is in as much trouble as as R um but Co
I mean I thought I've thought for a long
time that um you know the right-wing
press if you like Tories are very keen
to emphasize the divisions that labor
has over anti-Semitism and over Israel
and now over what's happening in Gaza
and perhaps have overdone it but then
when you look at last night's vote it is
a significant Rebellion I mean it is a
headache for K St I think it is I think
you can view this in two broadly
slightly different ways so from an
electoral perspective I don't think that
what happened last night or more broadly
what's happening in the Middle East and
the divisions within the labor party
will have much impact on the Electoral
situation um you could argue that the
country is split itself and you could
argue that most people according to the
polls don't really want to take sides on
this so you could say in terms of tone K
Dharma is on one level reflecting the
country as a whole wanting to see both
sides and wanting to see humanitarian
pors and and so forth um but at the same
time the majority of the country by a
large way and in particular labor voters
want a ceasefire m so what I would say
is I would say that so there's no real
electoral damage and K D remains 20 plus
points ahead in the
polls but it also reflects what I think
is his strategic weakness which is a
massive over emphasis on strategic
positioning so Kier star might's
actually very unlike Tony Blair they're
often compared but Tony Blair was a
conviction politician like Margaret
Thatcher in many respects K starma makes
his decisions and the people around him
based on defining who they are and who
they're not rather than taking specific
issues and running with them and I think
that is what he has done on this issue
starting off very badly with the LBC
interview because he was trying to use
it as a wedge issue to Define who he
wasn't and to make a point about who he
believes a labor party are but I think
what that what that will do is while it
won't directly affect him electorally it
creates a sense of who is K dama you
don't meet many people who are starites
that people in focus groups which we do
a lot you know are not are not wowed by
him yes they will vote for him as the
least worst option and I think this is
storing up problems for the future well
you do meet corbon knes don't you but
but uh plenty of them but I mean with
sty could you not frame it the other way
and say this is an issue where um rather
than bending With the Wind rather than
just being political he's taking a
political risk he's losing political
Capital within his own party to stand up
for what he thinks is the right thing
for labor to do I think I mean I think
that's exactly in a way what I'm trying
to articulate yeah so he's positioning
himself because he wants to be seen as
the Prime Minister the responsible prime
minister I'm quite intrigued that they
brief very openly that they following
the American line that's the sort of
thing that happens in politics but you
but they are saying out loud because I
think that on one level um is what they
believe strategically defines them as
Prime ministerial yes but you've got got
70 to 80% of the population saying they
want a ceasefire so there's two
different levels and he I think k d is
very much batting towards the
positioning to be seen as responsible
but I don't I think that is potentially
storing up problems for after the
election I think there's been some
missteps as well and there's been some
briefing around suggesting this is just
about a left right issue Etc I think if
you look at some of the names who quit
yesterday you know Jess Phillips I
wouldn't say was sort of necessarily of
the kind of
Carbonite exactly yeah well as some
would perhaps suggest it so I do think
that that although when we talk about
the kind of the big picture and she
Philip side
yeah well sort of you know I I would
want to classify Jess's ideology but I
think that it really I think while on
one the S National picture you can talk
about say it's not a huge impact there
were certain constituencies like Jess
Phillips which of course in 2005 were
very much impacted after the Iraq War
and that went to the lib Dems thereafter
so Jess Phillips only won that se in
2015 as result taking off the lib Dem so
I think that at a sort of granular level
some constituencies really of are of
concern I only make the point as well is
that you know there was a great line
today's morning Playbook which said that
one former Minister since this war
started 5 weeks ago has had 11,000
pieces of Correspondence about this
issue of which they say only three were
in favor supportive of Israel so my
point being is that you know this is a
huge amount of pressure going on behind
the scenes and I do agree there is some
issues of this approach of kind of
strategizing does mean that there's
going to be a lot of issues that store
up down the line and I think as we have
seen a couple of missteps over this as
the LBC interview demonstrated but also
they fail to take this seriously enough
there's a lot of anger bubbling up in
the early weeks and we've now seen the
consequences belatedly of that in last
night's vote can I ciz I think that's
right and I was quite surprised and
disappointed to hear Peter Kyle this
morning talk about this as a Muslim
versus Jewish issue in which labor are
seeking to kind of come down the middle
this is a massive issue and the and the
images on TVs get worse and worse every
day and I'm just you know this isn't
Iraq politically yet um or nor likely to
be but it is you know it is making
people slightly further down the line
wondering what does k starma stand for
you say you were disappointed by people
mentioning the the the Muslim element of
it I mean I would James say it's hard to
sort of collect the MPS that rebelled uh
last night under any sort of group but I
mean quite a lot of them are people with
constituencies with the large Muslim
population um so I mean it is a factor
is it not I think I think it is I mean I
I think and I don't like to talk
electorally you know in terms of
electoral Politics on an issue that is
so horrific that we see every day that
you know the damage that's being done
but
most you know bluntly most labor MPS
where there are large Muslim populations
are in City areas with safe labor seats
I think the issue goes beyond electoral
politics to issues of social cohesion so
I think MP with large Muslim communities
will be concerned about the feedback
they're getting and they'll be concerned
about the level of discontent within
their
constituencies rather than I think
worried about losing their seats
although that you know there might be
some examples of that yeah James do you
think this can only get worse as a
problem St because as the war goes on
and gets worse which seems to be likely
to happen uh the anger about it will
only Bubble Up um
the demands for the just humanitarian
pauses will be seen as not enough and
the demands for a ceasefire will only
increase yeah I mean remember of course
that these resignations they still going
be in the PLP there still going be noisy
voices we've already seen on our coffee
house list which we keep up to dat on
the website what a third of Labor and
peace have called for a ceasefire um
these are issues that are not going away
soon i' just like to make the point that
of course the reason reason we had this
vote last night was because of the S&P
motion the S&P have done a brilliant bit
of parliamentary chary in one point
exposing divisions in the main
opposition and differentiating
themselves on the huge substantial issue
next week we're going to see a vote at
Hollywood uh at which we expect Scottish
labor will be under a lot of pressure to
call for a ceasefire um I think because
of different reasons Etc there's a much
sort of Greater emphasis in Hollywood
and for a ceasefire um compared to say
you the conservative government here in
Westminster so I think that's going to
be the key issue and trying to exploit
those differences between holwood and
Westminster in terms of the labor
leadership remember of course I
mentioned Iraq ear in this conversation
Iraq was a big issue and why Scottish
labor lost support and there were the
accusation that Scottish labor was m a
branch office for the labor leadership
in Westminster which was seen as being
um you know not listening to the
concerns of those up in edinb so I
therefore think that this is going to be
a kind of issue that's going to be
bubbling away and certainly the S&P who
are really fearful about the impact that
labor seem to be making in in Scotland
in terms of making inroads into their
support there are going to be determined
to try and exploit this for all they can
and so last night's motion was a part of
that so I think there's a lot of
different moving pizzas of this picture
of which when we talk about say you know
big cities in in you know with sort of
big Muslim populations that's just one
part of it I do think that there's also
the Scottish element to consider as well
as you say Freddy it's one of those
things where it may not be seen as kind
of having an impact in the polls uh and
I think that the calculation made by
labor is that it's better to kind of
keep on this path of in order to be seen
as you know the Patriotic sensible party
Etc in which they're standing with the
the British government and in which that
they were trying to win over this 2019
Tories that's the calculation but there
are there's a lot of dangers within the
labor Coalition and I think that it
would be a mistake to underestimate the
sentiments and for the past 50 years or
so this has been a key fault line on the
left Israel Palestine so I think that
there's been a bit of a blasy attitude
in certain quarters about this well let
me ask you Cole and again I you know I
realized we're just talking to political
tactics about a human humanitarian
tragedy but the the Scottish element is
interesting certainly if you look at the
Corbin years going against slightly what
James said I mean you had someone who's
very obviously doish in his foreign
policy and yet labor didn't do as well
in Scotland as you might have expected
them to do I I I think throughout the
Corbin years you know it dispelled the
notion that what what what Scottish
labor needs is a leftwing leader and
that will bring back support that that
didn't happen that that was sort of
proved um not not to be the case um I
think during the Corbin years and before
and after until you know recently the
independence issue absolutely
dominated and the SNP were incredibly
skillful strategically in presenting
themselves as the center left party in
in Scotland so you know to that point
what what was Labor even for um and I
think they managed the SNP managed to
portray Scottish
independence like Scandinavia with good
health Ser good good Public Services
um and that is broadly where Scottish
you know Scottish voters are yes um I
think it's only in like the last six
months since there's been real tensions
within the SNP leadership and labor has
got an effective leader in Scotland that
Labor's managed to start pushing pushing
its way back yes um well we'll leave it
there but James and KL thank you very
much for coming on spectator
TV in a difficult week for the
government uh there has been one piece
of good news and that is that inflation
has dropped quite significantly uh in
October from
6.7% to
4.6% which is something for rishy sunak
and Jeremy Hunt to cheer about I'm
joined Now by Kate Andrews our economics
Editor to discuss uh Kate this is a
piece of good news isn't it it is a
piece of good news we can argue who
about who's really responsible for
inflation dropping but this is a
significant slowdown uh as you said it
it has slowed from 6.7% on the year in
September to
4.6% uh on the year in October and the
main reason for that is that a lot of
that um energy data that huge surge in
energy cost from last year has now
fallen out of the figures and instead
it's reflecting the fact that off gem
the energy regulator actually lowered
the price cap more recently so you're
now taking into account much better data
much better costs on energy so we've
seen that significant drop H I should
note that core inflation which excludes
those more volatile prices like energy
and food is still significantly higher
around
5.7% um that suggests that a lot of this
inflation has really ingrained itself
into the system prices are higher of
course the inflation rate being at 4.6%
overall means prices are still going up
so it's not to say that this is any less
pay F of a time for consumers but the
key here is that at the very start of
the Year Rishi sunak laid out five
pledges and having inflation was his
first one and he said his top priority
based on this data this most recent
update from the office for National
statistics The Government Can quite
safely say that it has achieved that
Target so one of five pledges obviously
this week they've had much much more
difficult political news on the Rwanda
ruling but on inflation they can say
that they've it well and he did also say
in the J es uh that he would deliver
inflation this year and you know uh
three months to go two months to go well
that's it he's hit it he's hit it ahead
of Target it looks like now we we should
note that in theory this this number
fluctuates inflation often doesn't go
down in a straight line as we've seen
this year so in November and December in
theory you could get a higher rate and
actually the the forecast look like it's
going to be really difficult now to take
the inflation rate from about 4.6% back
down to the banks Target of 2% % that
process looks like it's going to take
over a year to achieve they're not
expected that to be reached until 2025
so there's still a long way to go uh and
these things do fluctuate but it just it
seems almost certain now that the
government will be able to say that it
technically achieved its Target you
pointed to the crucial point there which
is uh that the government can't really
take credit for it uh there are much
bigger forces at play that it has
nothing to do with and the bank of
England plays a far more important role
but it is very keen to take credit for
it uh this morning at 8:59 a.m. I had an
email from Jeremy Hunt did she
personally yeah it felt very it felt
very personal it said well actually can
you read out the headline I'll read out
the headline it said have you seen our
promises Frederic that's the name that
the Tory party database has for me
clearly sure uh very formal Frederick
this is a quick note to let you know as
of today we've halved inflation that's
what we promised to do and we delivered
so why not share the news with a friend
of course I forwarded it straight to you
but you'd already got it I had already
got it but it was thoughtful of you to
to think of a friend um love those
phrases you know quick note quick we can
just circle back on those other pledges
sometime yes yeah it's quite irritating
isn't it especially when inflation
doesn't really feel like it's come down
at all and everybody is angry about high
prices voters are angry about high
prices to be to have the government sort
of bragging in his weird email marketing
way to you is is quite annoying I I
think there are two major risks here the
first is exactly what you've just said
Freddy that people receive that email
and think to themselves I don't feel
better off and that's because you're not
better off the situation is less bad
than it otherwise could be of course if
inflation we still in the double digits
but prices are still going up and
they're going up at a much higher rate
than the bank of England is supposed to
be targeting so come the end of the year
come next year people may still feel
worse off um I mean I because the
glimmer of good news here is that
average wages excluding bonuses do now
outpace inflation but that's only been
happening for a few months and it's only
about 1
1.5% so you know people might feel like
they can just about pay their bill in a
more comfortable way but nobody's
sitting around feeling especially Rich
because of this news that the government
has haded inflation the other difficulty
of course is that critics are going to
point out that um this is not really in
the government's remit uh Richi cak's
number one priority uh was something
that is ultimately determined by the
bank of England because they have the
tools to bring inflation down and that's
mainly interest rates and those 14
consecutive interest rate hikes those
painful hikes have largely contributed
to why inflation is haved now Jeremy
Hunt might say that the government does
our friend Jeremy our friend who
forwarded the email he might he might
say not in this email more broadly
speaking that the government does have a
role to play uh but that role is really
one of fiscal Prudence not direct action
so you could make the case that not
giving into demands for more spending
not giving into demands for more
subsidies as some Tred to do around
mortgages this year for example around
being more cautious with pay raises in
the public sector especially around the
NHS um that that that those decisions to
not spend money were an active part of
bringing inflation down he has a point I
see what he's saying um but we know that
that main lever is interest rates and
politicians simply have to watch on as
the bank of England the monetary policy
committee makes those decisions um the
bank has not been so great uh this has
been a painful process a slow process
great that we've had inflation but the
UK is still a bit of an outlier compared
to the euro Zone compared to the us our
inflation is still notably higher than
in those places so it's really hard for
anybody to Pat themselves on the back um
but again if we're framing this in terms
of pure politics something the Prime
Minister said judge me on you can judge
him on and say that he has technically
met his Target whether or not it was
ever his Target to meet whether or not
it's good enough are separate questions
but he has met what he said he'd do uh
uh speaking of the bank of England I
know one of your favorite games is guess
guess the bank right guess the bank
crate do love that game do you enjoy
when I play that in the office it's I
mean we have so much fun do um what uh
what do you what is your prediction I
mean everybody the market seem to be
anticipating now particularly with
America good inflation news on America
from America that uh rates will start
possibly even coming down now so we have
one more meeting for the monetary policy
committee before the end of the year
they have now decided they voted to to
hold rates twice so far at
5.25% those have been contested they've
been tighted as uh the governor of the
bank of England likes to say um you
don't have full agreement on the
committee I suspect that today's numbers
make it a lot less likely that we'll get
another rate raise uh because it really
does look like the rate raises we've had
so far are working um again you could
contest this and say well the bank is
still more than double its Target but
the fear of course is that if you take
those interest rates too far you could
trigger a recession I mean interest
rates are are taking that heat out of
the economy they're trying to make you
spend less money and if you get that
balance a bit wrong you fall on the
wrong side of a recession given the fact
that the UK essentially has virtually no
growth um the Q3 saw saw no growth if we
do get growth this year that's another
one of Rishi sunx pledges that will be
on a technicality basically um so the
bank of England has to be very cautious
with that I suspect today's figures make
it make it much more likely that we have
hit that Peak rate but as to when
interest rates start to come down Andrew
Bailey's been very clear that that's
going to be a while longer they don't
feel like the rate Heights so far have
been fully um fed through the system
they're still not fully felt uh they
feel like that needs to happen before
you start talking about bringing
bringing interest rates down and you've
written uh very eloquently as always
about uh
biomics and the similarities between
bomic and the way Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Hunt View the economy and are handling
the economies in their respective
countries um there's another similarity
I think in the showing up in the polls
which is that and certainly if if Jeremy
Hunt keeps talking about inflation like
that that uh voters nothing drives
voters more crazy in America than
Biden's White House constantly insisting
that the economy is great look at the
numbers they're fantastic whereas
everybody who's asked or large numbers
of the population who are asked uh feel
like they're significantly worse off
well this is fascinating because the
difference in America and the UK right
now is quite startling in America in Q3
they saw something very close to
5% uptick in GDP the UK saw
Zero yet Americans look at that figure
and all the pulling suggests that they
don't feel that they don't personally
feel the impact of that of that growth
and of course when we're talking about
GDP you know that that's that's a
meaningless phrase to most people we're
talking about wages we're talking about
new job opportunities we're talking
about opportunities overall more
Prosperity things people you know
actually do feel and understand and and
Americans aren't feeling that and it
does seem like that trillion dollar
Sugar Rush that Biden pumped into the
economy no one's really in the long-term
benefits of that I think the UK has a a
slightly different problem where there's
there's no growth to debate I mean how
it's a luxury to debate whether or not
5% growth is particularly meaningful or
not we're not in that position thank you
richy and Jeremy I suppose yeah and and
they and and they have but they've
they've been doing very different things
right Biden's been spending the money to
be fair rishy hunt and Jeremy cak have
also been spending quite a bit of money
um in the March budget this year their
their main rabbit out of the Hat was was
a lot of money for more child care
subsidies in the coming years um but
they have they have been more fiscally
prudent they have to be for many reasons
um the debacle with the last year's mini
budget and what that did to Market
confidence the UK is not the reserve
currency it can't just keep spending
money interest rates of course
skyrocketing the UK is looking to pay
over 100 billion pounds simply to
service the debt in this fiscal year you
don't get anything new for that that's
money we've already spent so the the
situations are are different the
responses are different that uniting
front Freddy is that you can point to
certain data points and and ministers
are in the UK and the US and saying look
at how great this is the response from
the public tends to be no sorry we don't
buy it we don't feel it um we're not
better off uh and this isn't really
party political so to speak because um
you've got a Democrat president you've
got a conservative prime minister people
just feel like the current economic
situation on both sides of the pond is
is fragile and frankly quite painful on
that cheerful note let's end it thank
you very much Kate thanks
Fred now let's talk about a frankly
terrifying topic which is the sharp
increase in loneliness and singledom or
singlehood uh among people especially
young people um there have been many
studies reporting uh an increase in
people being single uh and concomitant
rises in anxiet depression and suicide
as a result I'm delighted to be joined
by Dr Jean twangy who is the author of
uh a new book called Generations the
real differences between gen Z
Millennials Gen X Boomers and silence
and what they mean for America's future
Gan is a leading expert on this field
she's also the book the author of a book
called ien um that really broke down uh
a lot of the boundaries into the
research into this subject
and I'm also joined by the wonderful
Louis Perry who is a spectator
contributor and author of the case
against the sexual Revolution Louise uh
you've written about against uh the
sexual
Revolution um do you think this is a
combination of smartphones arriving on
top of habits that have been happening
for or been forming for uh decades now
that have led to young people being more
isolated yeah so I think smartphones are
surely a factor as as Jean says I think
there are lots of ways in which Tech has
kind of um add all the brains of young
people I mean the thing is about uh uh
getting married starting relationships
is it's really a very very difficult
coordination problem you know finding
the right person at the right time um
knowing that you're a good match and are
going to be a good match long term is
actually a really hard thing to do and
often you know if it works out sometimes
it works out just through luck but
what's more common I think in most
cultures is there actually to be more
sort of more cultural templates more
social guard rails less of an
expectation that young people will just
sort of work it out by themselves one
way or another um with the assistance of
various technology um you know one of
the problems I think that young people
do face now is that there isn't such an
obvious sort of cultural pathway laid
out for them in terms of this is what
you do at particular times this is how
you grow up like it's all it's kind of
all to play for as as Jean says you know
adolesence is increasingly extended um
people are having getting married and
having children much later in life that
these kind of adult Milestones are not
being um presented in the way that they
once um would have been and and what
we're mostly seeing you know you maybe
some people are really enjoying that
freedom really enjoying the um the
option to design their own life course
but actually I think most people find a
lot of um comfort and reassurance in
being um slightly more of fashioned
about these things uh Jin a lot of uh
young people uh suffered during lockdown
this is pretty well established um and
so therefore do we have a sort of triple
whammy effect of changing social
patterns over decades the smartphone and
then lockdown on top of that um which
meant that l a lot of children were only
only really had screens um and perhaps
family time uh to do socialization can
you give us a sort of sense sense of the
data there and and how socialization or
lack of it um is affecting young
people yeah I think that's true the
pandemic continued a lot of the same
trends that were already there in the
first place that you know anxiety and
depression among young people started to
rise around
2012 and then kept Rising during the
pandemic with that you know other layer
of stress and then the same thing with
these Trends in Social
isolation that we had already been
seeing that for quite a while that young
people were spending a lot less time
with each other in person it's almost
like they were in dress rehearsal for
the pandemic uh and didn't know it um
especially for Jen Z who I Define as was
born roughly 1995 to 2012 where they've
never known a world without the
smartphone so their social lives were
already heading in that direction of
isolation and then the pandemic put
another level on that in a way that I
think coming out of the pandemic it's
been even more difficult for a lot of
young people to come back to dating to
relationships to being with friends in
person um because they've often
forgotten how to do it and I think you
know a lot of older people felt that way
too but it was heightened for Gen Z
because adolescence and young adulthood
is a crucial period for developing those
social skills and that had already been
going away and then it just became the
next level with the pandemic lockdowns
can you tell us a little bit about gen Z
because I think there was a an
assumption perhaps that children who
grew up with the internet entirely uh
with social media entirely uh would be
able to come to terms with would grow
used to it in a way that perhaps
Millennials weren't able to um but as I
understand it the evidence points the
other
way yeah that's right and you know it's
it is interesting because that I've I've
heard variations on that argument you
know fair amount that say you know these
Technologies like social media was were
supposed to connect us they can allow us
to be constantly connected and you know
some people have said well you know if
Jen Z is spending spending a lot of time
on social media and online they're
mostly communicating with their friends
who cares you know that's the same thing
that that young people have always done
they're just doing it in a different way
through a different medium but one way
to answer that question about does it
matter and who cares is to say what's
the link to happiness what's the link to
mental health and as social media became
more popular as more people got
smartphones that's exactly when we saw
these very large increas es in anxiety
and depression and self harm and even
suicide among young adults and
adolesence plus we know that the more
hours a day a teen spends on social
media the more likely that he or she is
to be depressed some of the best data
that we have on that um comes from uh
the the uh UK Millennium cohort study
and it that's what it found that heavy
users of social media
among
14-year-olds twice as likely to be
depressed as those who did not use
social
media Louise uh a lot of people
dismissed fears about tech uh for a long
time as technophobic technophobia and so
on um I wonder to what extent people's
Instinct that there was something wrong
uh with spending a lot of time with
technology uh is down to their
understandings of tradition and their
understandings of important values that
are almost innate um and of course
Jean's very important work um has shown
that the data backs up what people's
instincts were but to what extent do you
think a sort of instinctive sense that
traditional family life was being lost
um through technology plays a
factor yeah I don't buy it when people
say oh well it's just like the printing
press isn't it I mean aside from the
fact the printing press um triggered
Wars of religion that lasted a century
you know which is maybe isn't a great
parallel if you're trying to Excuse
excuse the harms of the internet um I
mean I think it should be intuitive
particularly when it comes to the
effects on children because any adult
who uses screens regularly will should
surely notice the effect that it has on
them you know if you've spent hours
looking at a screen you're not just
going to have a sore neck you know you
do normally have a kind of psychological
Mala which I think um most people do
notice in themselves we know that
smartphones are very addictive we know
the you know using porn using social
media all of these things has has
affects our relationships our social Liv
I I think that it ought to be obvious
that all of those effects which adults
clearly identify um would be even more
um accute in children because they are
because because they're still developing
and we need to be even more cautious
around the sort of um stimuli which
we're presenting to Children which are
incredibly novel I mean this is the
thing about the internet that we just
can't understate it is so new still it
is so poorly understood still just
because it's it's only um arrived in our
lives in the last couple of decades and
I think that just hoping for the best
and kind of exposing children to this as
if they were guinea pigs um and crossing
our fingers is I think absolutely the
worst policy I think we should be much
more uh cautious when it comes to
children in particularly well Jean uh I
mean there we have it the problem is a
very very serious one uh the question of
course is what can be done about it um
obviously you can put pressure on social
pressure on parents uh to keep their
children off phones but that's doesn't
seem to be working uh
what can be
done well you know I think we have to
acknowledge that parents are in an
basically impossible situation because
there's so little
regulation around the internet and
social media you don't need parental
permission to open a social media
account it's very easy for kids and
teens to lie about their age so a lot of
times parents don't even know that their
kids have social media and with you know
School laptops and and uh other things
that have to be done using technology
some of the benefits of Technology how
do you know if your kid's doing homework
or is on Instagram it's very difficult
to know that unless you're hovering over
them all the time and who can do that I
have three kids myself and they're 11 14
and 17 so this is my daily life as well
as my research life um so I have a lot
of sympathy and empathy for parents
because it it is tough um I do think
there are a few things parents can do
try to make sure that your children
don't have their phones in their bedroom
overnight that's actually true for
adults too because you'll sleep better
um and if you think you need it because
it's your alarm clock buy an alarm clock
um and then if you have younger kids
delay getting them a full-blown
smartphone give them a flip phone or a
phone that's designed for kids where you
can only call uh text and take pictures
and that's it that doesn't have access
to the internet or to social media I
I've seen Jonathan ha uh who I know's
done lot of his work is is based on a
lot of your research
uh and he's uh saying that 14 is a
sensible age would would you put that at
about the right age for
parents um you mean to get to get a a
smartphone um perhaps although I I would
probably go for 16 I know have a
14-year-old and she has a phone that you
can only text and call and take pictures
um
so and I I think and John and I both
agree that for social media it should
not be inter uced until 16 some people
have even argued for 18 16 is a nice
compromise because then if young people
want to read more news or get involved
in politics they can do so um but then
you know we know in fact the great the
best data um available shows us that the
link between social media and depression
is larger for younger kids and teens so
when they're older they're they're
there's not as strong of a link to
depression and so I think that is
another big argument for age minimums
Louise I think your children are way too
young to be uh even considering uh smart
phones yet uh but I'd like to ask you
both actually uh because I know as a
parent the worst thing I do is set a
terrible example with smartphones by
being online all the time uh do you both
uh if it's not too invasive to ask uh do
you both uh have find yourselves
addicted to
smartphones uh horribly which is why I
have also I do sorts of things like I
have my phone set to grayscale for
instance if if your phone's grayscale
it's much less addictive I've found this
um I don't colleagues in journalism and
politics are astonished to hear I do not
have the Twitter app on my phone and I
in fact I have it I can only go on
Twitter 20 minutes a day I have a I have
a setting on my laptop you know I've
I've I have built I I can I I have
enough self- knowledge to realize that
I'm completely addicted to this stuff
which is why uh I I I impose limits on
myself and try really hard as well not
to look at the phone um when I'm with my
2-year-old and um he's in he's he's got
a lot of limits in store for him as well
I'm absolutely going to be applying all
of these restrictions I mean I
completely agree with Jean it's really
hard like parents are in a massive um
pickle which is where I honestly think
that parents would be so relieved if the
government brought in really quite
stract restrictions to for instance
Banning smartphones for under 16s I
think actually 99% of parents up and
down the land would be delighted because
it would take the burden off them to be
the ones there we go richy sunak needs a
popular policy
that uh and J you you I mean you are now
uh the leading Authority on the dangers
of a smartphone so you presume you're
under quite a lot of pressure yourself
to not be addicted to a
smartphone yes although um you know
similar to what Louise was saying it's
it's really it's all about limits um so
yeah that phone is not in my bedroom
overnight I do practice what I what I
preach I I tend not to to have it in my
pocket um I think that that that's often
helpful to not have it on you you know
all the time um to not have it around
when you're having a conversation you
know in in your family or with a friend
just you know kind of setting setting
those those reasonable limits um and
yeah same thing with me the only social
media that I have is Twitter and it's
only on my desktop I do not have it on
my phone and that's very
purposeful I tried the grayscale thing
but I found almost unconsciously I
switched it back to to color
uh but my my my father does a good thing
which is he turns off his mobile after
he's used it which I also think is quite
a good habit to get into um Jean and
Louise thank you very much for coming on
to spectator
TV that's all we've got time for uh I
hope that none of you are lonely of
course you're not you're watching
spectator TV probably glued to your
smartphone um but that's the best way to
be addicted to technology um do come
back next week and watch us again and I
hope you enjoyed the show bye-bye
[Music]